let's go next to andres from
zaragoza in spain right
hey how's it going david hey how are you
pretty good pretty good i have more of a
generalized kind of hypothesis in
general
more than really something uh specific
to our politics
all right i'll go for a generalized
hypothesis in general
yeah yeah for sure um it's uh it's
basically the idea that
um success in uh
in politics at all kind of breeds
corruption so if uh
if you're if your platform
is that you are specifically not corrupt
that you are uh you know
for example uh we'll say bernie sanders
whether or not you think bernie sanders
is uh
actually corrupt is neither here and
over there but a lot of his campaign is
he's not funded by the billionaires you
know that he is
um uh very trying to show that he is not
corrupt but
uh uh platforms like that usually just
don't
just get you know stomped out by people
who
are being paid off more people who are
more corrupt right
because yeah because success breeds
corruption
in politics
is basically my my idea there so you
kind of cut in and out there but
basically i
i agree with you in the bigger sense
which is as i've said before
counting on the people who got elected
under the current system
to completely change the system is a
long shot
because they themselves are at risk
of being taken out of power if they
change the system that got them into
power does that sort of make sense as a
general principle
certainly yeah yeah so one of the ways
that i think this could change would be
term limits because if you term limit
people where
there's no advantage there's no no let
me go back there's less of an
obvious incentive for them to keep the
system that worked for them in place
because either way they're going to be
term limited
i think maybe we would get more people
really willing to to radically change
the system that got them elected that's
one idea that i think would help
oh that's that's that's absolutely great
yeah it's because i i see
things like oh i forget how many it is
but mitch mcconnell is like
so many uh senate terms and it's
absolutely ridiculous
right no yeah absolutely term limits
just across the board
is definitely a step in the right
direction
but yeah absolutely i just think the um
just
the general just the way the the system
is created is
uh is is just yeah it just naturally
breeds corruption and stuff like that it
doesn't no doubt uh
generally represent the people they're
supposed to be representing and you know
republicans in the covid bill
recently is a very good example of that
no question yeah no question i think
you're thinking about this exactly uh
exactly the way i am
absolutely yeah well uh thank you really
much david
hey so so you live in spain but you're
an american
um no my uh my dad was actually in the
u.s air force so we met my mom in spain
right now i am uh actually living in
nebraska
uh if if you'll believe that but so you
tricked me
into thinking this was a more
interesting call by saying you were in
saragosa
um i i'm originally from uh sarakota
um but uh but no i i i uh
right now i i i'm not living there no
but i alright well we'll we'll allow it
it strikes me as a little dishonest but
we'll allow it
okay sorry about it all right thank you
okay uh great take care thank you no i
appreciate the call very important issue
very important issue
we are counting on the people who
benefit from the system
to change the system in some sense that
makes no sense all right let's take a
quick break
if you're holding do not hang up because
i'm going right back to the phones
momentarily if you are anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video